hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the hatman an indie
horror game that is actually out on
steam it is free but that's a
distinction
that not many indie horror games can
make we regret to inform you that your
daughter virginia has gone
missing no need to come here as we have
our full staff looking for her it's
totally fine
we lose patience all the time you would
just be
in the way dr henry hummer
superintendent of the canton asylum
for the insane so goody goody gumdrops
we get to go into an insane asylum
or i'm sure nothing supernatural will
happen
well that's actually kind of nice i
wonder if the floral pattern on that
door is a bit of a red herring
okay i'm sure nothing bad will happen
and oh look at
teddy bear oh the last time i saw teddy
bear like you
everything went totally horrible and
not good in any way at least you're
holding a magic heart
oh good and look it's a book with a face
on it click to activate
that
oh good
okay it was filled with nightmares i
would have much rather preferred it was
filled with bees
oh good it's whispering horrors into my
ears
press j to open them why am i carrying
the demon book that turned everything
into darkness
whatever you know what i'm not even
gonna question it anymore
i knew that things were gonna go bad as
soon as i went into the
insane asylum oh
good at least i got a flashlight with a
decent
why is it still whispering i thought
those whisperings were coming from my
book
oh no they're coming from that
okay you know i don't know much about
the hat man i know that he's another
creepypasta subject
okay so the whispering was coming from
the pages
now i'm lying awake in bed my next sore
from sleeping on one pillow
i asked for another but i need a
doctor's order to have more than one
my sleep medicine is worn off and i'm
once again a prisoner to my insomnia is
something happening out there
is there something you guys should know
about behind this book
okay i decided i might as well start
writing things down like they asked i'll
get bonus points towards extra dessert
or something for to do for now
i can hear the person in the next room
snoring people whispering in the phone
ringing at the nurse's station outside
i'm remembering the dream i had last
night where a tall man in a hat came by
my bedside and told me he would take me
away soon that's good
that's good news right there i'm making
a mental note to mention it to my doctor
later
probably also a good idea to do all
right
community group is over i'm why is my
heart getting faster
don't think i don't notice that
all right i'm not sure who thought
having insane people entertain each
other was a good idea
surprisingly everybody was there today
nobody killed themselves
that makes it a good day somebody cried
today but somebody always does
today's goal is to keep myself
distracted and try not to think of the
ways of killing myself
god this is depressing i told them i'm
past it been there done that i said
but i didn't think they didn't think it
was funny i remember something else
about my dream the man in the hat was
wearing all black
even his hat was black and his skin was
black his eyes i can't describe his eyes
why is my heart getting faster
or is it not getting faster is that just
in my
okay then i can't even describe his eyes
it was like he had no eyes
just empty sockets that seemed to be
pulling on my soul
can you stop that bass string there i'm
remembering being so
i'm trying to finish the story here
he said he would take me away from her
but i'm afraid to where he might take me
okay
didn't even hear a voice neighbor
voiceover about that
sorry that took so long i just had to
read through it and everyone kept
digging with me over here
do not mess with me bro
i'm a man on the edge and i got a
flashlight unless i'm a woman
okay why
something is doing that that tingles my
butt why are you bassy
okay i hope you're loading up for
something big
oh you're going away now come back i
like the tingles
locked out huh that's new all right
so the game has done well to build up
the atmosphere let's see if we can
actually deliver on that
i haven't actually done anything besides
someone in those bathrooms stalls
this is gonna go good
nothing just as i suspected is there
anything in the toilet that i need
why i'm sorry was that a very important
toilet that i didn't need to get near
okay
okay yeah i'm not wrong those weren't
just
pre-pruned those were actually planned
something's going on here those aren't
just a pattern
that's not just a steady rhythm that's
actually something
and i'm gonna ah never mind
what i was gonna say is i'm gonna okay
whoa i can't go backwards why can't i go
backwards
okay apparently i can't go backwards up
the stairs unless i
turn around oh i don't like this
i gotta say i don't like this
hello is somebody there
no no no no no oh it's just whispers
cause it's paige it's page
i don't know if this is acting like
slenderman and the more pages i get i'm
gonna summon something
but uh you guys can't see it because my
webcam may or may not be there but
there's a book with like five
dots and i've got four of them from the
pages i collected
uh process groups with the social
workers seemed like a huge waste of time
everything we talked about after they
said we were having sloppy joes for
lunch seemed to have nothing to do with
me
i tried bringing up my dream but that
just led to a discussion of more
medication
as everyone was getting up to leave
tanya walked me to the bookcase and
pulled out a book
she told me to read about the shadow
people and specifically someone referred
to as
the hat man she said i would find my
answer there
okie dokie she told you that there was a
magical book in an insane asylum library
that would have all the answers
i'm sure that this doesn't have anything
to do with mysticism and is totally
grounded in reality and everything's
gonna be
just peachy keen
also why am i here sorry
is someone there bing bong and the ring
wrong
is anybody there come in i'm stuck in an
insane asylum send someone to rescue me
immediately
what
okay is there something by that that i
need okay there's a
crawly space let's go in the air ducks
let's gordon freeman this [ __ ]
see what i can find hope nothing pops
out at me
oh nothing popped out of me but what was
that
stop just making noises and do something
you dick
oh this is where i got the page what was
the point of going in there
it was another way to go but i don't
think it actually resulted in anything
why you gotta be so rude
i don't like your tune
i gotta admit i'm pretty on edge from
this game i'm surprised
well i mean it was released on steam so
i was actually kind of had higher
expectations for what it was
gonna be and i'm actually not that
disappointed okay
so i don't know what the point of going
down there was was there anything on the
other side
maybe wait a minute that's not the way i
came
okay do we have something else here is
this actually the way i came and i just
don't remember it
it might be i might be going in circles
but then again it might be easy to get
turned around here
is anybody oh good more bathrooms i was
just hoping for this
come on nothing
nothing not even a toilet
nothing okay
nothing is anybody else really nervous
just me that's good a whole lot of
nothing
this is weird this is weird what was
that
what is that what is that got the tv
over there just turned off
shut up i don't want none of it some
electricity problem going on this game
has
great sound like i i saw a shadow
you can't tell me i didn't see a shadow
there i did oh my god i did
bathroom toilet toilet
no toilet last one
nothing even if i go in here god there's
nothing
why is there nothing i'm almost kind of
disappointed but i actually kind of
really happy that there was nothing
okay i am getting jittery
okay geez what the hell am i looking for
even
they mentioned something about a book of
the hat man and i only need one more
page to fill in my last green
circle what am i even looking for
there were three pages right off the bat
what do you want from me game
uh okay okay
hello more step is that a page in there
is that actually something
hello god that is disturbing okay got
the last page for this set
for recreational therapy i read tanya's
book i kept reading and reading
i was still reading when they called
lights out now i don't know
now i don't claim to know much but
reading about a man who paralyzes people
chokes him and steals our soul is now
recommended reading for insomniacs just
before bedtime
but now i know who i'm dealing with even
if he's only in my head
well he may be in your head but
apparently he's in mine now are you my
daughter
some is that why i got a letter that
pertained who you were
why you went missing and why i'm about
to go missing here
maybe i'm just in some shadow world and
actually everyone is moving
through me in the real world
wait a minute i hear some sort of static
oh what is that is that dead body on a
gurney why is that doing that
oh no zombie thumb for me i don't want
to play
oh that is a dead body and there's a
thumpy thumb coming from in here
oh don't wanna oh i don't wanna but i'm
obligated to do what it was nothing
are you kidding me it was nothing no
thumpy thump it was the thumpy thumb
oh that was the thumpy thump out there
okay
so the dead body was a thumpy thump well
you're gonna have to kick it up game
i've played a lot of horror games in my
time
and you need to really bring on the pain
my scare tolerance is pretty damn high
am i just going in circles i swear that
i've seen these places before
hello is anybody home can anybody hear
me
is that another dead body am i gonna
thumpy thump all over that
well this one isn't very thumpy thumpy
this place is
dark there's a okay why
why why why
no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no
oh that's okay it's a page
okay all right cool oh good my bar is
turning green
i missed last night's meds but tanya
came to my room and left them with a
note after she left i read the note it
said maybe not tonight
was she talking about my meds maybe the
hat man i need my meds
it is the only way i can sleep although
it is really quiet tonight
no snoring no one at the nurse's station
it's as if i'm the only one here
i'm attaching a picture here from the
book of the hat man
if i go missing you go look for him what
if i disappeared no one comes looking
i need to make it through the night i
agree why is it dark
why is it really really dark in this
room this is fun
this is a whole lot of fun i think i
think i'm not going crazy but this place
is getting more decrepit the farther i
go into it
am i getting a little twitchy i swear to
god i'm getting a little twitchier and i
do not like it
i don't think i missed any pages oh it's
just a picture of a dark spot
let me rub that out there oh it's a
nightmare man
good is he coming to take me away
ha-ha-ho-ho he he to the funny farm
who's going to know
no am i supposed to
no
no no
i think not i think not
where are you taking me where are you
taking me game were you taking us
you're in this with me guys no
that was a thingy i'm not getting around
here
you're back up you son of a [ __ ] holy
crap
that was something there's definitely
there's something there oh it's a gross
scooby cabber made of black goo
what is going on is he's just gonna be
chasing me
uh he's just gonna be chasing me he's
just gonna be chasing me i gotta lose
him uh where's the event where's the
event where's the event where's event
where's event there's a vent
there's a vent i'm gonna lose him in the
vent i'm gonna go around
i'm gonna go around the van and i'm
gonna go around i'm never gonna see him
ever ever ever ever again
or maybe i'm gonna be dead being dead is
another option that i could take
i don't prefer that option but it's
definitely possible
where is he
did i lose him he's behind me maybe i
just need to hurry the f
up now where'd i go i don't know which
way i went i hope i'm going the right
way
oh i'm so not oh which way do i go which
way do i go what do i do
this is the wrong way the wrong way
no no no no no oh what do i do what do i
do it's a black coop
oh it's a black goopy man
oh i saw the picture that's what doomed
me
ain't going to get me no no
no i'm ready for you come on come on
what are you big
baby huh baby man baby shadow man
ain't too afraid to come near me just
cuz i'm
a little shaky
where'd you go where'd you go mr shadow
man
is that you are you there are you right
in front of me
i can't quite see it's real
are you right there i can't see oh my
god he's right there isn't he
maybe i shouldn't be staring right at
him some for some reason can't come in
here
why can't he oh what do i do i'm gonna
die
i'm gonna die so hard okay i'm just just
gonna go for it
black gooby black goopy come on
that goopy come on come and get me black
gooby gabba
come on come on hmm
right now
oh i can't believe that worked i thought
it was dead
what's there what d toe ab
dear to ob what does that mean have i
been here before
what is that i don't wanna
i don't wanna know i don't want none of
that
so do you squeak on me oh you squeak on
me you douche
what is happening why is it happening
where is it happening
can i escape no into a padded cell i go
i'm i'm not doing okay
which way do i go which way do i go well
there's the familiar sound
no
okay i think this is the way where i
first
thanks
thing is that the way out please tell me
it's some sort of way out oh good i get
to go upstairs
i don't think i've heard
what why am i sliding backwards
what
that is like the least favorite sound of
mine
oh that's a bad sound
oh that's just
oh good do i drop down into the vent
okay where did this take me please don't
tell me it took me right back to where i
was okay doesn't look like it
okay so so so what about that
oh what about that was that just another
way to get away from the
douche the dark
douche okay
uh what another set of stairs what do
you mean another set of stairs
i just went up where else could i go oh
is that dark been bashed oh something
bad in here
something bad in here oh something mad
in here
i've got so many heebie-jeebies about
this
mmm that's a bad sound wait a minute no
no no no no
that can't just be a dead end ah [ __ ]
jesus get out of here what do i do about
you
what do i do about you
peter why is there a piano
why was there a piano was this something
important
come on there was something important
over there i know there was i don't even
know what the objective of what i'm
supposed to do is
oh you guys may be laughing at me but
you're trying to ah it's another one
or it's the same one i don't know oh
what do i do where's the piano
where's the ding dong give me the piano
stop it stop that silliness right in
are you doing in the bathroom there mr
shadow man you need to take a tinkle
oh what is that i got a box of bed
i captured my soul i didn't know what i
was supposed to
do well all right then i guess that's it
for me
jesus that is a creepy ass game holy
crap
oh my god i wanna i need to i need to
try to beat it i need to try to beat it
so
uh i don't like russia through this
i'm gonna run smack into him i probably
passed by so many pages before nope he's
in there
i probably passed by so many pages
before because
i wasn't paying attention for the
whispers i was too busy running for my
gosh
darn life cool cool cool ten times cool
it's all very cool it's all very cool no
no no no no no no no
no shut up no it's you squeaky squeaky
damn to the poopy
oh is this new does it randomize while i
play
i swear i just went back here and it was
totally what is there going on
what is the going on
wait matches i got a box of matches
that's right i need to find some matches
why why do i need matches i don't know
why i need matches
whispers whispers
yes oh crap more whispers
crap don't have time gotta go gotta get
young
that's what he was waiting for he's
waiting for me to pick up the matches so
that i can keep
going with the pages oh god what's
happening
what am i supposed to find now oh god it
changes so frequently
it changes to match what's that let's
try holding the ground
no no
pissing at us god this is hard
all right come on buddy i'm back to
where i was you ain't gonna give me this
time
not this time bruh not this time friend
friend oh rendo [ __ ]
poopy ass butts oh poopy ass which way
do i go
i can't go this way
flat bar oh
i don't know what to do with flat bar
oh i hear a page i also see a dead body
god i gotta go gotta go gotta go i'm
gone
was that another one god damn it thank
you damn it
what excuse me pardon me i'm busy
do not bother me don't do that jimmy
i heard whispering
oh i'm about to win
yes oh god i gotta get five more
was that another one oh you're so nice
to me
it's too nice give me that thank you
you're so nice to me i'm out of here i'm
outtie i'm outtie
but i bet the next one's gonna be an
object
crap crap crap crap crap crap crap
crapples
crabbles to grapples come on come on
yeah you can't get none of us
oh where do i go i've been going in
circles
what do i do what
i got it get it use it do it do it to it
get it i'm really trying
how do i do i want to do it i want to do
it so hard i want to do it so badly
oh come on give it to me do it get up in
there
flat bar it okay i got a flat bar
something
something something's getting crowbarred
this place is really messed up i go down
one hall back track everything was
changed
this is amazing i have no idea which way
is forward but since i can't go back i
need to keep looking there has to be
something in this place i need to find
it i didn't see him but i heard him he
was so close i heard his groan
after he left i realized the hallway is
he behind me
i ran down at a huge hole and if he
chased me down i would have been stuck
the only thing big enough to put across
was the nail bore in the wall next to it
but i'm not strong enough to bring it up
but with the pry bar i
am oh i get it i get it i get it now i
know what i need to do oh oh
no you were right behind me
okay this is normal normal behavior
normal fun land going to have a good
time
with friends and family someone's coming
to kill me
but it ain't gonna be me i'm doing good
i'm i'm doing good in this neighborhood
neighbor neighbor neighborhood
ha ha get ready to get barred
yeah oh god yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh gently oh gently oh so
gently
yeah yeah what was that
now now what
now what do i do stop squeaking in me
what do i do what are we doing oh okay
need to find a good place to sit there's
another page in there
gotta find it gotta find it gotta get it
gotta get it get it get it is he right
there he's right out there
which way where is he he's right there
okay that's where he is he was right
there right there is where he is he's
right there right there
where's the other page to say i need to
be able to read him are you going to
come kill me
okay yeah is the dream or was it
nice or no one judging me no disappoint
i can't wait man i need to figure out
how to beat him
why does it tell me [ __ ] oh i'm in the
oh something happened the hallway with a
hole in and now his board across the leg
the wall just crumbled or someone made
it crumble
i'm here with that person i'm gonna save
you
i'm gonna save you lucy lou god i just
realized
okay oh piss and poopy
oh there we go jeez
my god that took forever that legit took
so
long okay now i should be able to find
like the last page or something
hopefully
there we go got that no you don't
what's going on
not today not today not today not ever
not today
i've come way too all the doors open oh
no
god damn it [ __ ] wait am i live
oh come the [ __ ] on god
damn it you [ __ ] i was wandering
around for half a goddamn
hour and i walked right into you at the
last second what the [ __ ]
oh god damn this is some [ __ ]
this is some flying [ __ ] here this
isn't
fair i came so far and i turned around
and i even got away from you you son of
a [ __ ]
you ghostly oozy [ __ ] ugly
piece of crap yeah you're so scared
you're the hat man you got a scary hat
screw you go to hell and stay there
where you deserve to be
oh god i got a page ooh some slender
clone gonna come in here and tell me
that i need to be scared of you when in
reality you gotta be scared of me
yeah keep whispering your jibber jabber
in my ear i don't care i got no damn
patience for it
i know exactly what i need to do so just
let me do it so that i can get
out of here oh we're gonna be in a crazy
psycho bonkers world in an insane asylum
it's gonna be so much fun and original
for a horror game
i got something in my eye how about you
just wait patiently for me to beat your
dumb game
whispers now i need to go find a box of
matches for some that reason
to summon a seance to kick your ass
i'll kick your ass once shut
up no one cares
no one cares oh you're gonna come at me
nope
oh i crouched out your brain just can't
okay you found me okay never mind
oh and now you're taking forever to give
me the box of masses i know i need
matches i don't even care that i don't
know what i need them for
i just want them okay okay how about
that okay
nice nice good nice happy bathroom
bathrooms matches finally
body skeleton e
oh no he's coming into the room
come on in what is warm we got a nice
hot
dead skeleton soup going on there no
fine go screw yourself
oh the neighbors again god
what a budget it's amazing how
dramatically the mood of this game has
shifted
from absolute terror and intrigue to
just
the worst douchiness battle
bathroom bedroom blood death
blood bottle insane
bonkers i'll find it one of these days
one of these days i'm gonna find it
eventually
doesn't matter that i found it already
ah good
you see a goat sir guten gunther
yes yes very good now that opened up
not going here pop this out here i got
an old fruits
i can go find the elevator and get the
hell out of here wait
i'm going to elevator land markiplier
now that you got the foods what are you
going to do
i'm going to disney world not taking you
with me oh
no i'll take him with me this is gonna
be another goddamn maze because i've
only found the elevator
once and it was at the end of a hallway
i just gotta keep going to the end of
hallways until i find it
i found it what do you know
oh i'm going down that seems like the
opposite of what i want
oh tell me there's more oh
i've been playing this game for over a
goddamn hour
recording oh okay i got i guess i gotta
find more pages
down here now cause down here is where
it's wetter and butter and
fun that was what the well that
huh but okay
well there's a page here somewhere
okay
a broken elevator could it even be fixed
i wonder where it goes up i
always behind me okay
oh this is a new area is it the morgue
oop got another one now i'm red
now i'm red red i'm red with rage
all right let's get back into it now
that i'm actually conquering new
territory here
wait a minute what the oh my god
you're talking to you telling me that
this just leads to new place this is
messed up i just wandered into what has
been the electroshock room and there's
somebody
in there still getting treated what
looks like this place is playing for
kings huh
well fine if that's how you're gonna be
i'm just going till i beat it get out of
my way chair i don't have time for you
oh look he's come to play the elevator
is here to stay
it takes me nowhere i want to go
maybe i'll visit my friend mo
so i'm just guessing i'm looking for
another whatever
of mystery ah
got another one the elevator is working
now how's this possible
but i don't see anyone someone reading
my journal but that can't be possible my
journal with me all the time i read that
fear is a problem reaction
the more i'm afraid okay bye okay bye
okay bye i got no gosh darn idea if i'm
actually making any progress
hello hang on a second i heard whispers
yes perfect just what i needed road down
the elevator oh
not sure how floors it was favorite is
the morgue far into the dresser
found a cross what
there's something on the other side of
the room i'm gonna get it i'm gonna get
it i'm gonna get
get get it right in here yes please
thank you and what'd you give me
sorry to think i'm here forever my own
private hell it's frustrating the word
that's
am i gone now did they even notice what
they even care if you guys need to read
this more
uh just pause the game you need a little
talk okay
hand man you and me hear me bro
mono himano come on let's throw down
oh let's not i'll go the other way now i
i'm not going to go running into the hat
man just now i'm just on a hunch
over there over there over here over
there
over there yeah this might just be the
last one
my thing's already blood red that was a
close one the man quartered me i had
nowhere to go
pulled out my lucky crossing that backed
off i asked him like a thousand
questions and he just stared at me
when i asked him about getting out of a
bunch of images last year my nine i'm
carrying a lucky cross section but
journal is all dark and creepy
uh he's out there isn't he after they're
seeing that i got past them and ran i
need to get away and write it down so i
can't hold the crossing right at the
same i found a place hey but
so i need to find the cross that's what
i need to do
that's my next objective can you find
the morgue
me ah oh god damn it
what the oh it broke oh from the
beginning i felt someone is helping me
someone was reading my journal or my
mind and helping me deal with my
problems
as hard as it is to imagine the hat man
showed me my mommy are trying to find
i'm the mom i'm a mama trying to get me
home
oh the thing i don't get is she was
carrying my lucky cross
she could never have gotten to it even
if she knew where it was
maybe it's my turn to help her mom if
you're reading this and putting the
cross on my bed then i'll go hide find
my bed and he'll be there maybe i don't
deserve it but i need your help
i want another chance i want to go back
it's up to you gotta find the bed
can't kill me yet you dick kill me yeah
all right is this a this guy
what is that oh no
why are the doors locking up why are all
the doors getting shut
what does this mean these doors are
appearing that weren't here before
what does this mean why am i getting
closed in
why are they boxing me in not a day
not today
yes five get away ah this is not the
cross
six four one three
okay what do i do now
what do i do now i don't know what i do
now
no okay
oh this isn't good i like this
what the ground kind of goes no he's
mine
no no put it down no no no god damn it
no
no no no no
i'm so angry i'm so angry
man i'm gonna take your hand i don't
wanna eat it i'm gonna eat your freaking
hat
i had this though to help me now sort of
give me a hug
i'm above all the kid
started out so good and then i got
really bad
it took too long and now my voice is
gonna hurt
okay okay okay
so that was the hat man as you can see
the ending is never ending you just die
the hat man gets you stealing your soul
and everybody in the world dies a
horrible death forget you ever existed
and moves on with their life just like
i'm going to do from this game so if you
want to play this free on steam try to
beat is really
good so thanks again everybody for
watching
and as always i will see you in the next
video
bye-bye and this house is terrible
whoever designed it it's falling apart
the rooms go nowhere
ah [ __ ] oh god
this is freaking me out oh my god
freaky